con los requisitos del programa por
ejemplo el patrocinador dentro de
Estados Unidos y con la advertencia de
la deportación de migrantes irregulares
es factible que los flujos migratorios
disminuyan en la frontera Sur
yo creo que lo que podrá abrir Es una
poesía para una población muy limitada
poder acceder a ese programa de
humanitario Pero hay mucha gente que
sigue intentando llegar a Estados Unidos
van a esperar más y más en la frontera
con Estados Unidos esperando quizás
otros cambios en las políticas
migratorias si se bajó los flujos de
personas venezolanas a partir de la
expansión de ese programa en octubre del
año pasado es lo que está esperando el
gobierno que bajan los números de
personas de Nicaragua de Cuba de Haití
pero hay que ver porque la necesidad es
tanto y hay mucha gente que simplemente
no van a poder esperar en sus países de
origen bueno justamente qué pasa con los
migrantes que provienen de otras
naciones
es justamente una complicación con todas
esas medidas porque están diseñados
solamente a los países donde Estados
Unidos no tiene relaciones diplomáticos
o se les dificulta de mover a las
personas Entonces qué pasa con personas
de México en Guatemala Honduras y este
El Salvador que que México recibe estas
personas que también tienen necesidades
de protección están siendo muy excluidas
de poder Acceder al estilo en Estados
Unidos y lo que está haciendo el
gobierno y determinar Quiénes pueden
entrar déjame le ganas entonces con base
en nacionalidad y no en sus necesidades
bueno y junto con el programa La Casa
Blanca anunció 23 millones de dólares
adicionales para México y Centroamérica
Para apoyar a estas naciones en materia
migratoria realmente suficiente
No no es suficiente Y es parte de los
financiamiento que está dando los
Estados Unidos en los últimos meses de
apoyar a la región pero es una gota a
nivel de la necesidad que van a tener y
yo creo que hay que Resaltar que México
mismo está aceptando ahora 30.000
personas más al mes en sus ciudades
fronterizas donde no tiene la capacidad
de alojarlos de cuidarlos y mucho menos
protegerlos de diferentes riesgos y
delitos que se han cometido en su contra